in March 2015 the laws of space and time  were violated the future isn't just  something that happens it's a Google  force with a great sense of humor action  think your little crazy  [Music]  who's they my gang Yankees who aren't  magic  oh why don't you just have what you want  you ever  what  [Music]  yeah tre what up I got something to say  it's a mouthful  thanks pointed for tearing gashes right  tell me I want to be a killer I can't  let anyone else die because of me you  did the right thing coming here  you have to ask yourselves but the real  answer to you question  is that when it feels scary to jump in  that is exactly when you jump are you  familiar with deprogramming back ok  [Music]  we match  Oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]